THIS MEETING TO ORDER -- WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE UNTIL
WE HAVE QUORUM I WELCOME TO
TODAY'S JEDI HEARING I WANT TO
FIRST -- JUST MAKE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE NINE BILLS
ON FILE TODAY THERE ARE THREE
BILLS ON CONSENT NO BILLS HAVE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE CALENDAR.
ALL BILLS INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN TODAY'S BILL
ANALYSIS ITEM THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE ITEM SEVEN
AB THREE SEVENTY ONE AND ITEM
EIGHT AB SIX THIRTY NINE ARE ALL
ON CONSENT.
I WANTED JUST NOTE MEMBERS THAT
THERE IS A LIST A SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION BUT YOU
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED A COPY AT
YOUR DESK.
THEIR LETTERS WHICH ARRIVED IN
THE COMMITTEE PASSED THE
DEADLINE TO BE INCLUDED ON THE
BILL ANALYSIS WE HAVE INCLUDED
THEM ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL LIST
THAT YOU HAVE WITH YOU TODAY.
AND THERE ARE ALSO PUBLIC --
COPIES AVAILABLE RIGHT OUTSIDE
OUR COMMITTEE ROOM.
LET US NOW BEGAN WITH THEIR
FIRST BILL WE HAVE ITEM ONE AB
TWO FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI PLEASE ADD
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWO FORTY FIVE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO START -- BY -- ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED ON PAGE TEN
OF THE ANALYSIS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
AND I THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL.
AB TWO FORTY FIVE WILL CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION COMMISSION.
THIS IS MY SECOND ATTEMPT TO GET
THIS COMMISSION ESTABLISHED IN
SO -- I WILL -- RESERVE A MY
COMMENTS FOR QUESTIONS BUT IN
BRIEF -- THIS COMMISSION WILL
BRING THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE TOGETHER WITH THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY LEADERS TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL
AND GLOBAL LEADERSHIP AND
AEROSPACE INNOVATION IN JOB
CREATION.
AS CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AEROSPACE I'M PROUD
OF THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS
HOME. TO MAJOR AEROSPACE
COMPANIES LIKE BOEING NORTHROP
GRUMMAN AND SPACEX.
AS WELL AS A VAST NETWORK
NETWORK OF SMALLER COMPANIES
THAT PROVIDE THE INDUSTRY SUPPLY
CHAIN.
HOWEVER OTHER STATES LIKE TEXAS
AND FLORIDA ARE AGGRESSIVELY
TRYING TO LEARN THESE COMPANIES
AND JOBS TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THIS
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT GROW AND
CHAMPION AEROSPACE INNOVATION
AND JOBS RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL WITH
CO AUTHORS FROM BOTH PARTIES --
AND IDEA WOULD TO ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TODAY'S BILL
[inaudible]
HERE. TO DO THAT THEY CAN REACH.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LAURIE CAMERA FROM A
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THE MORNING OF THE S. R. THORN
CAL CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE MACHINISTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN FIVE FOR
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHWEST
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF AIRPORT
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
FROM CAROL FORD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PILOTS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING NAM BUILDER WITH
THE NATIONAL BUSINESS AVIATION
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AND BUSINESSES I
REPRESENT AB.
TWO FORTY FIVE OR I SUPPORTED
WITH.
FORTY FIVE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M SCOTT MALTA I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
MANAGER MY NAME IS AL THE BILL.
AND I AM -- NEVER SPACE
EXECUTIVE -- THIRTY PLUS YEARS
AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
EFFORT IS BEING DONE I JUST CAN
NOT SUPPORTED IN ITS CURRENT
FORM AND I HAVE SOME COMMENTS IF
I MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS POINT TAUGHT.
WE CAN ADDRESS OUT SOON AS WE
FINISH WITH THE SUPPORT.
VERY WELL THANK YOU.
SIR JOHNSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
MELISSA MCCARTHY WITH AIRCRAFT
OWNERS AND PILOTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENT -- OVER -- THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AIRCRAFT OWNERS
AND PILOTS -- NATIONWIDE OVER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW WE
SUPPORT THE BILL -- BUT WE DO
THINK THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO
HAVE -- SOME TYPE OF NATIONAL --
REPRESENTATION SO THAT THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
COMPARISON TO STATES WHERE THIS
HAS WORKED AND WHERE THIS HAS
NOT WORKED SO THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM THAT -- BUT WE DO SUPPORT
THAT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN.
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
ANYONE ELSE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
ANYONE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
I GUESS YOU FIGURED OUT I WAS
GOING TO TALK FOR A LONG TIME --
NOT A GERMAN -- MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- I REALLY APPLAUD
THE EFFORTS BY A BY THE
HONORABLE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
ITS IT'S TRULY NEEDED --
COMMISSION.
AND I APPLAUD THE EFFORTS THAT --
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE --
MY CONCERN IS IS IS AS FOLLOWS --
I TO SUPPORT THE EFFORT BUT THE
CURRENTS OF THE COMMISSION AS IT
IS RIGHT NOWIS GOING TO CAUSES
A LOT OF CHALLENGES SEE THAT.
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE HAVE --
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
INDUSTRIES HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
NEEDS.
AND AS SUCH I WOULD ENCOURAGE
HIM TO BE LOOKED AT SEPARATELY.
YOU HAVE A MANUFACTURING SECTOR
VERSUS A SERVICE ORIENTED
INDUSTRY THE AIRPORTS AND
WHATNOT.
ARE TWO TOTALLY DIFFERENT
ANIMALS THE THE ONLY THING IN
COMMON IS THAT THEY BOTH FLY
AIRCRAFT.
AND SO I THINK REALLY THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE AT THE TWO
INDUSTRIES VERY MUCH SEPARATELY.
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS -- THE
FUNDING ALSO NEEDS TO BE
PROVIDED BY THE STATE IN THE
SAME MANNER IT IS PROVIDED FOR
IN THE INTEREST AIR SPACE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HOWEVER
AIRSPACE HAPPENS TO BE LARGER
THAN ENTERTAINMENT.
AND AGRICULTURE INDUSTRIES
COMBINED.
BUT THAT SINK IN FOR JUST A
SECOND.
ENTERTAINMENT AGRICULTURE IS
SMALLER THAN AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
AND WE HAVE A COMMISSION ON ON
ENTERTAINMENT BUT AS YET WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO SUPPORT OUR
AIRSPACE INDUSTRY.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF INDUSTRY
SUPPORTING THIS ARE FUNDING THIS
IS VERY VERY SLIM.
RUN THE RISK OF HAVING A PAY TO
PLAY SITUATION AND NO ONE WANTS
TO BE A PART OF IF THE
COMMISSION IS TO SERVE TWO
MASTERS TO INDUSTRIES.
AND THE THE THIS COMMISSION IS
EXPECTED TO FUND IT.
THE PLAYERS TO FIND IT.
HOW LONG WILL THEY FUNDED IF
MONIES ARE SENT US -- SPENT ON
THE OPPOSITE INDUSTRY OF THEIR
OWN.
SO YOU HAVE LET'S SAY AN
AIRSPACE PRIME.
ACTUALLY FINDING THIS AND THEN
ALL THOSE MONIES GET FUNDED TO
GET UTILIZED IN AND BUILDING
SOME NEW AIRPORTS ARE UPDATING
OUR AIRPORTS WHICH I I AGREE ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
BUT HOW LONG IS LIKE FINDING
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE IF THAT'S
THE CASE -- THE COMMISSION
MEMBER MEMBERSHIP MUST BE MADE
UP OF SEASON AIRSPACE EXECUTIVES
WITH TWENTY PLUS YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
THEY HAVE MANAGED COMPANIES WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE POLITICAL
APPOINT APPOINTEES ON SUCH A
DESPERATELY NEEDED COMMISSION.
SOMETIME AGO I AM I MADE SOME --
SEA LEVEL FOCUS GROUPS ON
AEROSPACE COMPANIES SPECIFICALLY
SEA LEVEL.
HERE IS TO JUST SAID THAT THE
COUPLE OF A OF ITEMS -- THEY ARE
CITY STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS WHICH DIFFER SO IT'S
EASIER.
CORD IMPORT CHEAPER TO PAY THE
FINES AND TO TRY TO MEET THEM
ALL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CIOS TELL ME.
I CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY SOMEBODY
JUST TO MEET ALL REGULATIONS I
JUST PAY THE FINE.
EPA'S FORCING COMPANIES TO MOVE
OUT OF STATE WE NEED TO BE FIRM
AND HAVING A CLEAN STATE.
BUT BE PRAGMATIC ABOUT WILL BE
COULD BE FLEXIBLE Là.
I THINK THAT IS A SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT HI HOW
CAN BE BE REASONABLE ABOUT SOME
THE CHANGE OR BE IMPOSED ON
INDUSTRY IN ORDER TO KEEP ON
HERE WHILE STILL MAINTAINING IT
COMING STATE.
WORKMAN'S COMP IS INCREDIBLY
HIGH INCOMES UP AS THE NUMBER
ONE COMPLAINT FROM MANY FACTORS
THIS NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT MUCH
THE SAME AS OSHA. 8290% OF
COMPANIES ARE SMALL AND THAT
LESS THAN FIVE MILLION RANGE
8290% OF ALL THESE COMPANIES.
AND IT AND THEIR AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES OF COURSE.
SO WE NEED TO FIND A WAY TO KEEP
THEM COMPETITIVE AND STAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WE MUCH CHANGE A REGULATORY
NOT MIND SET OF I'VE GOT YOU
HERE'S THE FINE? TWO HOW CAN WE
HELP YOU MAKE YOU SUCCEED.
THAT'S AT THE HEART OF WHAT WE
NEED TO TO DO IT JUST A COUPLE
MORE COMMENTS AND I'LL BE DONE.
THIS CAN ALL BE MANAGED TO
WRIGGLE BIZ AND ALL WE ASK IS
THAT ANOTHER SEASON EXECUTIVE
RUNS IT SO THAT IT CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE CALIFORNIA HAS A
VIBRANT ECONOMY.
AS IN THE TOP FIVE OR SO
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD AND IT IS
PARTLY BECAUSE OF AIR SPACE NOT
IN SPITE OF IT.
WE NEED TO NURTURE IT BACK TO
HEALTH OR ELSE OTHER STATES AND
MEXICO WILL HAPPILY TAKEN IN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RECOGNIZING THE
PRESENTS A QUORUM SECRETARY CAME
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHAIR CERVANTES.
CHAU CERVANTES HERE BY SIR
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN PRESENT RAMOS.
ALMOST PRESENT REAVIS SMITH.
SMITH PRESENT MANAGER WITH A
QUORUM.
AT THIS TIME I DO WANT TO GIVE
OUR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS
SHOULD THERE BE ANY [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MENTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS OUR
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS -- BILL UP -- I
WAS SURPRISED TO FIND OUT WHEN I
STARTED BRINGING -- THIS AN
OFFICE THAT THERE'S SO MANY
AEROSPACE ENGINEERS -- IN MY
DISTRICT SO WHEN THE QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE IN TERMS OF FUNDING
MECHANISM 50% COMING FROM THE
STATE 50% COMING FROM OUTSIDE --
ENTITIES -- DO YOU FORESEE A
POSSIBILITY IN THE FUTURE THAT
THE 50% COMING FROM OUTSIDE
ENTITIES COULD ON BE UP AND DOWN
BECAUSE I ASSUME THAT.
IS -- TO SELF INTEREST --
INITIATIVES INVOLVED -- THEY
MADE NO LONGER WISH TO PARTAKE
IN FUNDING THE COMMISSION THANK
YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
FOR YOUR QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO BE OF A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
AND IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT A
PARTNERSHIP WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE'S GOT.
SOME SKIN IN THE GAME YOU KNOW
AND AND THIS GOT A LITTLE
HISTORY ALSO THE LAST YEAR --
WHEN I INTRODUCED THIS BILL?
OUR LAST SESSION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MADE
IT CLEAR THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT --
TO EXPAND ANY STATE FUNDS FOR
THE SUPPORT OF THIS COMMISSION
AND SO THAT IS WHY.
LAST SESSION WHEN INTRODUCED
THIS BILL WE STARTED WITH THE WE
WE WOULD YOU KNOW Q. HEARING.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WANTED
TO GET SOME COMMISSION I MEAN
THIS MAY NOT BE PERFECT I I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- THAT -- THERE
THERE MAY BE CONCERNS ABOUT --
ABOUT -- THEY DID THE PRIVATE
FUNDING OF THIS COMMISSION BUT
IN A NUMBER ONE IT'S IT WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING -- TO MAKE THIS A A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP IN
NUMBER TWO BECAUSE OF THAT
HISTORY THE RELUCTANCE OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT LEAST
IN THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION --
NOT WANTING -- TO TO TO TO FIND --
THAT THIS COMMISSION.
AND NOW I'M JUST TRYING TO BE --
PRAGMATIC HERE I I BELIEVE THAT --
AND AEROSPACE COMMISSION THAT
ADDRESSES MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY BY THIS --
PREVIOUS GENTLEMAN -- WOULD BE
ADDRESSED BY THIS COMMISSION BUT
YOU KNOW A COMMISSION THAT IS
HALF FUNDED BY THE STATE AND
HALF OF FUNDED BY.
BY BY PRIVATE -- TO BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IS BETTER THAN NO
COMMISSION -- NUMBER TWO THIS IS
AN ONGOING EFFORT -- YOU KNOW WE
NEED -- TO FRANKLY WE WE WE NEED
TO HAVE A IS THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR STEP UP ON THIS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW -- IF IF -- IF -- THE
INDUSTRY WANTS THE STATE TO
CHAMPION THIS THIS -- A
COMMISSION THAN WERE ASKING YOU
KNOW TO MEET HALFWAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I LOVE
THE IDEA OF HAVING A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS I THINK
IT'S GREAT.
RECENT INJURY GETTING BOTH --
INTERESTS ON THE TABLE.
IF THERE ARE OUTSIDE PRIVATE
ENTITIES ARE COMMON TO SUPPORT
COMMISSION FINANCIALLY WOULD
THEY BE BARRED FROM SITTING ON
THE COMMISSION ITSELF.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT.
TO HAVE -- AS THE GENTLEMAN
INDICATED THAT A PAY TO PLAY
SITUATION -- YOU KNOW -- SO WE
WE DO HAVE LIMITATIONS IN THE
BILL IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW THE
THE THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
COMMISSION THAT ANYONE SINGLE
ENTITY CAN.
CAN BE -- CONTRIBUTING TO BETTER
YOU KNOW WE WE WE'RE ENGAGE IN
THOSE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO
SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS WORK
BED BUT CLEARLY WE DON'T WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE ANY -- NOT
ONLY -- YOU KNOW -- TWO EIGHTY
ANY APPEARANCE OF ANY PAY TO
PLAY SITUATION. ONE FINAL
QUESTION I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR YOUR ANSWERS -- HOW WERE
THE COMMISSION -- APPOINTEES
DECIDED I AM SURE IT'S SO
ONGOING CONVERSATION FOR
INSTANCE -- IS THERE ANY
INTEREST OF LOOKING AT
COMMISSION IS TO HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN C. PORTS.
EXCEPT FOR A WELL WE WE DO A
SPECIFIED IN IN THE AND THE BILL
HOW -- THE THE GOVERNOR THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE WILL --
MAKE THEAPPOINTMENTS TO THE
COMMISSION -- AND WE SPECIFY
WHAT BACKGROUNDS IN A WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW A A HEALTHY AND ROBUST MIX
OF REPRESENTATION FROM THE LARGE --
FROM THE SMALL MEDIUM SIZE --
FROM UNIVERSITIES FROM -- FROM
AIRPORTS -- AND AS WELL AS FROM
LABOR AND SO -- WE YOU KNOW HAVE
TRIED -- TO ENSURE THAT -- EVERY
STAKEHOLDER AND AND INDUSTRY HAS
A SEAT ON THE COMMISSION -- BUT
I AM OPEN TO ANY SUGGESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOU --
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS ARE I
THINK THIS IS A A GOOD BILL AND
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT -- AS A
MOVES TOWARD THOSE CHANGES SO --
WILL BE ANSWERED I LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
BILL -- HOWEVER TODAY I WILL BE
LÏNG AWFUL CERTAINLY RESERVE
MY RIGHT TO SUPPORT THE BILL IS
REALLY WANT TO GET THERE -- AND
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GET THERE
IT IS MY SINCERE HOPE WITH.
OF THOSE QUESTIONS -- THE ANSWER
THAT THIS GO AROUND THAT GOES
THE GOVERNOR AND THE THE
GOVERNOR TO SIGN AND SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWERS I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORD.
I DO WANT TO JUST TOUCH ON THE
QUESTION YOU JUST ASKED -- THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ON PAGE THREE
OF THE ANALYSIS IT DOES LIST THE
BOARD APPOINTMENTS -- AND ONE
MEMBER FROM A SEAPORT THAT
EXPORT AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
EQUIPMENT IS.
ON THAT SO I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT DOT ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH IN THE
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS.
BUT THE AUTHOR LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
CERVANTES HIGH.
CHAIRS AROUND AS I BY SIR
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHEN [inaudible]
MOST.
RAMOS I READ THIS.
REAVIS HIGH SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH HI.
THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
TO OUR COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
.
NEXT WE HAVE ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
AB.
TWO THIRTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS SHALL BE ACCEPTING
THESE AMENDMENTS LISTED AND
COMMENT.
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS.
AS AMENDED AB TWO THIRTY WILL
BRING MUCH NEEDED REFORMS TO
IMPROVE THE MANAGEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM.
A STATE AUDIT RELEASED IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR CONCLUDED
THAT MANY WARNING DEPARTMENTS
CURRENTLY DO NOT.
SUBS DO A SUBSTANDARD JOB IN
OBTAINING AND VERIFYING THE BID
CERTIFICATION FOR PROJECTS
INTENDED TO BENEFIT DISABLED
VETERANS.
AB TWO THIRTY ADDRESSES THE
POTENTIAL DISABLED VETERANS.
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES NOT BEING
PAID FOR WORK INCLUDED IN
INITIAL BID BY FOCUSING ON THE
STATE'S ADMINISTRATIVE DUTY TO
ENSURE.
THAT COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
PRIME CONTRACTOR AT THE TIME OF
THE AWARD ARE MET WITHOUT THIS
DATA THE STATE CANNOT ASSESS
WHETHER THE PROGRAM'S MEETING
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
INCREASE DISABLED VETERAN.
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PARTICIPATION IN STATE
PROCUREMENT AND ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM THAT
BENEFITS DISABLED VETERANS.
IN RESPONSE TO AN EARLIER TWENTY
FOURTEEN STATE AUDIT AND THEIR
OWN REVIEW OF THE PROGRAM.
TGS AND CAL THAT HAD COMMITTED
TO OVERSEE CORRECT PAYMENTS TO
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE SUBCONTRACTORS THIS
SIMPLY HAS NOT HAPPENED.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS LEGISLATION
SEEKS TO REQUIRE A CONSISTENT
COLLECTION AND VERIFICATION OF
SOME COBB SUBCONTRACTOR PAYMENT
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE ARE BEING
USED PROPERLY AND PAID PROMPTLY.
BY FOCUSING ON STATE CONTRACTING
PRACTICES AB TWO THIRTY SIX
IMPROVE.
THE PROGRAM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DISABLED BETTER SPINNERS OWNERS
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AFFECT
LARGELY LETS THESE VETERANS
BUSINESS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
STEVE NODES -- I OWN A DB YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA -- MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT SALES I'M IN SUPPORT.
THEY FORMED A GLOBAL BLUE EIGHT
YEAR DVB IN THE STATE I. T.
SALES SUPPORT.
SEE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CNN -- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN AND THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECT PLEASURABLE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWO THIRTY
THE MOTION IS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
CHAIR CERVANTES AYE CHAU
CERVANTES ANA PLACER CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHEN.
CHEN I RAMOS [inaudible]
REAVIS.
REAVIS HIGH SMITH.
SMITH HI.
I THINK ABOUT IT.
WILL REMAIN ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
MANAGER AT YOUR PLEASURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TODAY I'LL BE PRESENTING ON
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN FOUR TWO I AB. SEVEN FOUR
TO ESTABLISH IS THE OFFICE OF
PLAYSPACE ECONOMIC STRATEGIES
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SUPPORTING LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT WALL CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENTLY RANKED HAVING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE STATE FOR WHICH THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY REMAINS OUT OF REACH.
ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC IN
COMPLEX CHALLENGES FACED BY
NEIGHBORHOODS THESE NEIGHBORHOOD
REQUIRE DEEP ECONOMIC AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WORK
WITHOUT STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CAPACITY AT THE
LOCAL OR REGIONAL LEVELS RE
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES COULD
BYPASS.
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
OF OUR STATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FOUR TWO
CALLS FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
NEW CENTERS WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH WOULD CHARGE WITHIN WHICH
THEY WILL BE CHARGED WITH
ASSISTING COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
BEEN FEDERALLY DESIGNED AS
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS PROMISES OWNS
OR ANY OTHER GEOGRAPHICALLY
TARGETED ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AREAS.
THERE ARE TWO PRIMARY REASONS
JUST SAP WISH THE OFFICE A PLACE
BASS ECONOMIC STRATEGIES FIRST
THE STATE CURRENTLY LACKS A
CENTRAL POINT OF CONTACT. FOR
LOCAL AND REGIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS TO ENGAGE WITH THE
STATE.
AND SECONDLY IN ORDER TO
COMPETITIVELY ATTRACT
OPPORTUNITIES ON INVESTMENT
LEADERSHIP -- THIS LEADERSHIP IN
THE STATE WILL HAVE. TO HAPPEN.
ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT OF A PLACE
BASED MODEL IS THAT IT BUILDS
UPON THE UNIQUE FEATURES OF A
COMMUNITY AND EXISTING PHYSICAL
AND SOCIETAL AS ASSETS IN
CLOSING BY STRENGTHENING IN
AREAS LOCAL IDENTITY AND
HIGHLIGHTING IS EXISTING
RESOURCES.
WILL BE ONE STEP CLOSER TO BRING
IN OUR MORE ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
UP TO PARITY TO OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS PAT FONG
COULD YOU SHE COULD YOU START
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS PAT PHONE
KUSHIDA AND I'M PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR HISTORY
THE CHAMBERS THE LARGEST
STATEWIDE AT THE CHAMBER IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE WORK CONSISTENTLY TO
CREATE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY -- IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES -- WE OPERATE.
WE ARE CHAMBER.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WE ADVOCATE
AND WE DO A LOT OF POLICY WOULD
BE AT BUT WE ACTUALLY OPERATE
MORE LIKE AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENTITY WE OPERATE TO
FEDERAL CENTERS.
THE CENTERS ARE FOCUSED ON
BUILDING MINORITY BUSINESS
CAPACITY IN GLOBAL EXPORT
TRANSACTIONS AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CONTRACTING WITH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION --
WE ALSO -- ARE -- AN AFFILIATE
NETWORK AFFILIATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S SPDC -- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THESE
PARTNERSHIPS REQUIRE --
ATTENTION VERTICALLY AROUND HOW
WE CONTINUE TO DO THIS WORK --
CREATING REGIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES.
WE ARE ALSO CURRENTLY STANDING
UP AN OPPORTUNITY FUND HERE IN
THE SACRAMENTO REGION -- BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE CAN TRACK INVESTMENT TO THESE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND WE'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES
AND PROGRAMS OF WORK A VITAL TO
EVERY COMMUNITY THAT WANTS TO
COMPETE AND EXPAND AND WE WE
KNOW.
THAT NOT ALL NOT ALL LOCAL
ECONOMIES DEVELOPED -- EQUALLY.
COM AND CAL ASIAN CHAMBERS ONE
OF THE STATE'S KEY PARTNERS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THIS
BILL STANCE TO HELP AND SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE ARE NOW MAJORITY MINORITY
STATE AND WE KNOW THAT ALL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HAS ITS
LOCAL.
AND SOME REGIONAL ECONOMIES ARE
DOING BETTER THAN OTHERS IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE HAVE AN
INCLUSIVE.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY
STRATEGY THAT ENABLES OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES -- THE
ABILITY TO FULLY PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY THANK YOU.
YEAH A FRIEND SOLO WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT.
MY JOB IS TO GIVE YOU A QUICK
BACKDROP ABOUT THE BILLS THAT
YOU'RE ALL GOING TO BE SEEING
THROUGH THE REST OF THE SESSION.
THE DEAL WITH THIS QUESTION OF
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND HOW THEY
COULD BE MAXIMIZED.
INCREASE INVESTMENT IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
THIS CAME OUT OF A CHANGE TO
FEDERAL TAX LAW.
THE OBJECTIVE WAS TO TRY TO FREE
UP STRANDED RESOURCES FROM
CAPITAL GAINS -- WHERE AN OF THE
SALE OF AN ASSET WAS CREATED AND
THAT MONEY WAS STRANDED SIMPLY
BECAUSE FEDERAL TAX -- A RATES
WERE TOO HIGH SO WE HAVE THIS
NEW -- OPPORTUNITY IF YOU WILL
IN CALIFORNIA THEY BEGIN TO TRY
TO CAPTURE THIS RESOURCE WHICH
IS A PRIVATE EQUITY RESOURCE
THAT WILL HELP BOLSTER OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
AND THE ECONOMIC SUMMIT LAST
YEAR SPENT A GOOD BIT OF TIME
THINKING THROUGH.
WHAT WHAT WOULD HELP MAXIMIZE
THIS AND CAME UP WITH BASICALLY
FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS THEIR
OUTLINED ON PAGE OF FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS OF L. A. B.?
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE ALL GIVE
THE SERGEANT -- THE OUTLINE OF A
FRAMEWORK THAT WE HAVE PUT
TOGETHER AGAIN TO TRY TO
MAXIMIZE THIS NEAR FIVE PIECES
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SEEING
PORTIONS OF IT IN THE COMMITTEES
ACTIVITY -- EACH OF YOU HAVE
SOME NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS IN YOUR DISTRICTS SO IT'S
GOING TO BE OUR IMPORTANT FOR
YOU BECAUSE LEGISLATORS OF
POLICYMAKERS. TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT THE BEST WAY TO MAXIMIZE
THAT RESOURCE.
AND SO OF THOSE ARE FOR ITEMS
QUICKLY ONE OF THEM IS.
TO GET THE JOB -- EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS TO BEGIN TO FOCUS ON
HOW THEY CAN PROVIDE EXISTING
RESOURCES WEATHER'S FINANCING
RESOURCES OR OTHERS.
THAT WILL FOCUS ON BENEFITS TO
OPPORTUNITIES ON THE SECOND
WOULD IS PROBABLY THE ONE THE
PEOPLE ARE PAYING THE MOST
ATTENTION TO IS ABOUT HOW STATE
TAX LAW OUGHT TO CONFORM.
A DO DO NOT BE OVERWHELMED BY
THAT DEBATE IN THAT THAT'S THE
ONLY ISSUE HERE IT'S NOT.
THERE ARE OTHERS ARE AS
IMPORTANT AS IT IS -- IT'S NOT
IN THE PURVIEW AT THE MOMENT OF
THE TAX COMMITTEES IT'S IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT YOU SHOULD
PAY SOME ATTENTION TO HOW.
THE STATE WILL CONFORM IT'S TAX
LAW -- TO THIS -- TREATMENT OF
OUR CAPITAL GAINS RESOURCES --
THE THIRD IS THE QUESTION OF
LOCAL CAPACITY -- WHAT'S THE
CHAIR INDICATED IS AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THIS -- BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO HAVE CAPACITY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN ORDER TO ORGANIZE
IN ORDER THEM -- MAXIMIZE THAT
RESOURCE THERE IS I HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PUT RESOURCES
INTO COMMUNITIES ARE LIVING GIVE
YOU GOT A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
WHERE THE CITY OF STOCKTON.
I GOT A GRANT FROM THE
ROCKEFELLER -- IN THEIR SO
CALLED ACCELERATOR PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE GETTING ORGANIZED IN
ORDER TO ATTRACT CAPITAL OR
SOMETHING SIMILAR IS GOING ON IN
SAN JOSE -- WE NEED TO HAVE A
BROADER A CENTER RESOURCES FOR
IT OF REGULATORY ISSUES ARE
ALWAYS A QUESTION -- THEY AND
FINALLY PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT IS HOW DOES THE STATE
MEASURE THE RESULTS OF THAT
INVESTMENT.
THOSE FIVE THINGS ARE THINGS
THAT THE THE ECONOMIC SUMMER
CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
NEEDED TO BE PART OF A BROADER --
SET A POLICY CHOICES AND OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE SEEING
BITS AND PIECES OF THOSE ARE
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU FOLLOW
THAT SORT OF OVERALL --
OBJECTIVE TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
OPPORTUNITY ZONE INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE SUPPORTERS
THAT I WILL ALLOW THEM TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR EFFORTS IN THIS AREA --
BLAKE CHRISTIAN ATTACKS PARTNER
WITH H. C. VI T. IN LONG BEACH
I'VE BEEN A PRACTICING CPA FOR
THIRTY NINE YEARS -- THIS THIS
IS THE MOST POWERFUL
[inaudible]
TAX DIVERSIFICATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL THAT I'VE SEEN
IN MY CAREER FRANKLY.
AND WE'RE WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF FORMING ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS JUST OUR FIRM.
SO IT'S IT'S AMAZINGLY POPULAR
MUCH MORE SO THAN I THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO BE -- AND IF IT
FILLS A HOLE THAT WAS LEFT BY --
CALIFORNIA ELIMINATING THE
REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AND IT'S
TO ME IT'S KIND OF THE PERFECT
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TOOL --
THE YOU KNOW SO I THINK WAS VERY
WELL CRAFTED I AGREE -- WITH
MISTER SILVER THAT -- YOU KNOW
WE NEED TRANSPARENCY IN THERE
ARE SOME BILLS I THINK ON THE
SENATE SIDE TO INCREASE --
MEASURING THEIR COMMUNITY IMPACT
AND I'M I'M ALL FOR THAT -- THE
DID JUST JUST -- MY FINAL
COMMENT IS.
HI IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE ARE THERE BE CALIFORNIA
CONFORMITY AND I KNOW THAT --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS ANNOUNCED
SOME YOU KNOW SOME LIMITED
PROJECTS GREEN PROJECTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- OF THAT
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE YOU
KNOW WILL WILL DEPLOY IN THE
NEXT NEXT COUPLE MONTHS --
WITHIN OUR FIRM -- HALF OF THAT
IS GOING OUT OF STATE BECAUSE OF
THE NON CONFORMITY -- A TAX A
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER CAN DO A
PROJECT IN ANOTHER STATE AND NOT
INCREASE THEIR CALIFORNIA TAX
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY TAXED ON
IT.
AND HOWEVER.
TAXPAYERS IN OTHER STATES ARE
GOING TO BE INVESTING IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT WILL
INCREASE THEIR THEIR NET TAX SO.
ANYWAY THE CONFORMITY IT IS IS A
REAL HIGH PRIORITY AND I KNOW
CENTER HERTZBERG IS -- HAS
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION SO WE'LL
BE WATCHING THAT OUT BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT THE HOUSE TO LOOK
AT THAT ALSO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME HERE -- I
MET HORTON I'M WITH -- THE
MILKEN INSTITUTE MILKEN
INSTITUTE IS A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT ECONOMIC POLICY THINK
TANK.
AND WHILE WE CAN'T.
NECESSARILY SUPPORTTHE BILL IN
NAME THE CONCEPT OF A
CENTRALIZED -- VEHICLE AROUND
PLACE BASED INVESTMENTS -- AND
AND THAT SUPPORTS A FRAMEWORK
AROUND OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
ANOTHER COMMUNITY FINANCE TOOLS
I WOULD ECHO -- THE SENTIMENTS
THAT WERE ALREADY SHARED HERE
AND AND THERE'S A GOOD SUMMARY
HERE ON ON PAGE SEVEN OF OF THE
STAFF REPORT FOR SOME.
FORTY TWO AS WHAT FRED SAID --
YOU KNOW NO MATTER HOW THE
FEDERAL REGULATION SHAPE UP AT
THAT TREASURY WHAT WHAT THE
STATE CAN DO IS REALLY CLEAN IN
ON THIS CONCEPT OF A A SHOVEL
READY PROJECT PIPELINE WHETHER
THAT COMES FROM OUR EXISTING.
PROJECTS THAT THAT ARE AT OUR
BOND ISSUERS OR FOR OUR OUR OUR
NPOS WE CAN MOBILIZE THOSE -- TO
UP TO FIND A RETURN NOT JUST
FROM INVESTORS STANDPOINT BUT
THAT REALLY HIGHLIGHT OUR
PRIORITIES FROM COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WHETHER THAT BE
HOUSING -- INFRASTRUCTURE
RENEWABLE ENERGY PLAYS WE WE CAN
KIND OF UP.
IN VIEW THOSE PRIORITIES IN THIS
FRAMEWORK AND AYE AYE IT'S UP
IT'S UP IT'S A GREAT CONCEPT SO
THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE.
AND I WILL CLOSE BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
BRIEFLY SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE -- WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH IN THE
SECOND BY SOMEONE A REGIS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER TO AB SEVEN FORTY
TWO THE MOTION IS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION.
CHAIR CERVANTES HI CHAIR
CERVANTES ANA PLACER CUNNINGHAM.
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM ON CHANNEL.
CHANNEL ON A CHEN.
CHEN FIVE RAMOS REAVIS.
REVERSE AYE SMITH.
SMITH BY.
WE'LL PUT THAT BELONG CALL FOR
THE MISSING MEMBERS TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE WHICH IS A COMMITTEE BILL
AB.
EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT MADAM CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU -- I THINK YOU.
VICE CHAIR AND ARE.
MY FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
LET ME JUST START BY ACCEPTING
OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN COMMON FOR OF THE
ANALYSIS SMALL BUSINESSES PLAY
AN ESSENTIAL ROLE WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
CONTRIBUTING THE MOST NET NEW
JOBS.
AND HELPING DISBURSE THE
FINANCIAL ADVANTAGES AT THE
STATE'S GLOBALLY CONNECTED
ECONOMY.
STEEPER CREEK PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN REPRESENT AN
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC TOOL TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT WELL STATE AGENCIES
HAVE MET THE 25% SMALL BUSINESS
SCHOOL.
AND FOUR OUT OF THE SIX REPORT
PERIODS CHALLENGES STILL
EXISTING CODIFICATION OF THE 25%.
WOULD PROVIDE A STRONGER
ENGAGE WITH LOW AND NON
PERFORMING STATE DEPARTMENTS
WITH ME TODAY ARE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
LET THEM INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
WHEN THEY SPEAK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND OF
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LAURIE CAMERA ON BEHALF OF SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE TGS SMALL
BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL -- AND
THIS ISSUE OF THE 25% GOAL.
IS RAISED AT EVERY MEETING SO WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES BILL WE URGE
YOUR I FELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE BILL.
I'M SORRY SOME OF THAT I'M SURE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I'M A ROOKIE AT THIS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SOME
REMEMBER SMITH IS THEIR SECOND
AND SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHTEEN OH
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
WITHIN MOMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
CHAIR CERVANTES.
CHAU CERVANTES ON A VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM I'D CHANNEL.
CHANNEL ON A CHEN.
CHEN AYE RAMA'S REAVIS.
REAVIS ON SMITH.
SMITH HI.
THAT BILL ON CALL.
MOVING TO ITEM SIX I BELIEVE.
JUST COMMITTEE BILL -- EIGHTEEN
OH NINE LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN COMMON
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS AND ONE
ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENT RELATED TO CONCERNS
RAISED TO THE COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS
CHANGES TO THE D. V. B. E.
PROGRAM IN RESPONSE TO THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN STATE AUDITOR REPORTS
WHICH FOUND AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THAT DEPARTMENTS FAILED TO
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
AND RECORD KEEPING PROTOCOLS ON
CONTRACTS INVOLVING DVB EASE.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN OH NINE
ADDRESSES TWO OF THE ISSUES
RAISED IN THE AUDIENCE ONE
ENHANCING THE TRACKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR EFFECTIVENESS
OF STATE OUTREACH ACTIVITIES.
AND TO REQUIRES THE AWARDING
DEPARTMENTS TO POST ON THEIR
WEBSITE THE ALREADY MANDATED
CERTIFICATION BY THE PRIME BY
THE TIME THE DVB EASE HAVE BEEN
PAID.
WITH ME TODAY OUR NUMBER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT -- WHICH
ARE WITH US.
IT WILL BE TESTIFYING.
THANK YOU PLEASE APPROACH
MICROPHONE -- GOOD MORNING --
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE -- I'M
STEVE NOTES -- OWNER VISUAL ON
DISTRIBUTION -- SACRAMENTO BASED --
DVD COMPANY SELLING MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT -- I'VE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR SEVEN YEARS
EMPLOYEES SIX INDIVIDUALS HALF
OF WITH WHOM ARE VETERANS --
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB -- AB --
EIGHTEEN OH NINE WITH THE
AMENDMENT. TO SECTION DE.
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE LOCAL TV
COMMUNITY -- I'M LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE --
IN THE FUTURE FOR ANY FUTURE
BILLS THAT POTENTIALLY COULD
HELP THE TV PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AFFECT
WORKS ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
STATES VETERANS BUSINESS
ALLIANCE A NEW CLIENT FOR US
WERE VERY PROUD TO BE WORKING
WITH THEM.
WELCOME TO THE PARTY ON THIS
BILL A LITTLE BIT LATE WE
APOLOGIZE BUT WE WORK WITH.
THE THE CHAIR HAND ARE EXCELLENT
STAFF TONY THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
WHAT THE FOR A A WORKING WITH IS
THE LAST MOMENT AND WE HAVE A
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE THANK YOU --
DAY FOR BACK AGAIN GLOBAL BLUE.
WHEN ECHOES THESE COMMENTS WE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND ALL THE
HARD WORK AND EVERYTHING AND?
IT DOES ALLOW US BOTH THE HIGHER
VETERANS AND HELP OTHER VETERANS
GET STARTED.
SO SUPPORT THE BILL WITH HIM AND
FULLY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MAN -- TIM DIVINE
PRESENT OWNER OF AB ENTERPRISE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE
TECHNICOLOR TERRY NICE SUPPORT
EIGHT VETERANS WE HAVE A STAFF
OF TWENTY EIGHT WE SUPPORT
EIGHTEEN OH NINE AS WRITTEN WITH
THE AMENDMENTS.
HOWEVER IT FAILS TO ADDRESS THE
TRUE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
THE REPORTS WRITTEN BY THE TWO
DAUGHTERS ARE EXCELLENT IN BOTH
FOURTEEN AND NINETEEN THE BILL
NEEDS TO ADDRESS AS A CALLS OUT
FOR THE ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE MAKE
TECHNICAL MEN'S TO CLARIFY THE
EXISTING D. G. S.
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CLARIFICATION IS NEEDED ON THAT
NOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REGIS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
CHAIR CERVANTES I'M.
SURE CERVANTES I'D BUY STIR
CUNNINGHAM.
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
CHANNEL NINE CHEN.
CHEN I PROMISE REAVIS.
REAVIS HIGH SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH.
WE'LL PUT THAT BELONG CALL
[inaudible]
MR
PERFECT.
WE CAN MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
PLEASE BEGAN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
SMALL BUSINESSES FORM A VITAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S JOBS IN
COMMERCIAL NETWORK AND I THINK
WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FACT
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL CREATE.
OVER 50% OF THE NEW JOBS WILL BE
WOULD BE -- CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
HOWEVER IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
SOMETIMES FOR CALIFORNIA IF A
SMALL BUSINESSES TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEX LABYRINTH OF REGULATIONS.
THAT EXIST BOTH HERE AND IN
OTHER STATES AND CAL SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE A UNIQUE
DISADVANTAGE COMPARED WITH LARGE
BUSINESSES BECAUSE THEY TO OFF
OFTEN DON'T HAVE THE FULL TIME
COMPLIANCE PERSONNEL NECESSARY.
TO BE AWARE AND TO COMPLY WITH
THOSE REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE
THE SMALL BUSINESS REGULATORY
FAIRNESS ACT CREATES A VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED -- EXEMPTION
THAT ALLOWS.
STATE AGENCIES THE DISCRETION TO
WAIVE OR REDUCE PENALTIES ARE
LEVIED AGAINST SMALL BUSINESSES
AND I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU A STORY
FROM WHEN THIS BILL WAS CRAFTED
THAT.
I THINK WILL ILLUSTRATE WHY THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL IS SO CUTE.
I SPOKE WITH A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN BACK OF BILL CALIFORNIA
SHE OWNED A RESTAURANT LOCATED
IN A HUNDRED YEAR OLD BUILDING.
SHE I HAD AN INSPECTION ONE DAY
WERE FIVE DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES CAME TO HER BUSINESS
AND INSPECTED NOT ONLY FOR FOOD
PREPARATION BUT ALSO THE
PREMISES -- SHE PASSED WITH
FLYING COLORS ALL OF THE FOOD
PREPARATION INSPECTIONS HOWEVER.
THE AGENCIES DID HIGHLIGHT A
NUMBER OF PROBLEMS WITH THE
PROMISE THAT SHE WAS ON MOST OF
THEM RELATED TO THE FACT THAT
THE BUILDING WAS A HUNDRED YEARS
OLD.
AND SO SHE WAS ISSUED A LEVER IN
DIFFERENT CITATIONS.
I'LL TELL YOU THE THE NIT
PICKING US OF THE CITATIONS ARE
ONE OF THE CITATIONS WAS -- FOR
A TWENTY FIVE CENT.
COVER MISSING ON A AN ELECTRICAL
OUTLET.
AND THE FINE FOR THAT ONE
CITATION WAS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
FINES FOR THE CITATIONS WAS
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SHE
DIDN'T HAVE IT SO SHE WAS FORCED
TO CLOSE OUR BUSINESS.
AND WHEN SHE TOLD ME THIS THE
TEARS WERE RUNNING DOWN HER FACE
AND SHE JUST.
COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING
LIKE A TWENTY FIVE CENT PLASTIC
ELECTRIC OUTLET COVER WAS GOING
TO FORCE HER TO LAY OFF
EMPLOYEES IN CLOSER BUSINESS.
SO THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO TAKE
CARE OF I DON'T TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT SOMETHING NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
ALLOWING SMALL BUSINESSES NOT TO
COMPLY WITH REGULATIONS THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT THE ATTENTION
INTENT HERE WE'RE TRYING.
TO A VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED
ABILITY TO GIVE DISCRETION TO
STATE AGENCIES WERE NOT FORCING
STATE AGENCIES NOT TO FIND
BUSINESSES -- WE'RE GIVING THEM
DISCRETION TO REDUCE THE FINES
OR ELIMINATE THE FINES IF THEY
FEEL THE CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANTED
AND WE'VE GIVEN THEM SOME
GUIDANCE ON WHEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES MIGHT WARRANTED
FOR EXAMPLE A FIRST TIME
OFFENDER.
WHEN THE IT -- VIOLATION WAS
INADVERTENT WHEN THE VIOLATION
WAS RELATIVELY MINOR WHEN THE
BUSINESS COOPERATED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION AND WHEN THE
VIOLATION WAS CORRECTED.
AND THOSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING THIS IN A TO BE CLEAR
THESE AGENCIES.
ARE IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
ALREADY WANT TO REDUCE THE FINES
NOTE NO STATE AGENCY WANTS TO
LEVY A FINE ON A BUSINESS THAT'S
SO ONEROUS.
THAT THAT BUSINESSES IS FORCED
TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS BUT RIGHT
NOW WITH HANDCUFF THEM BECAUSE
STATE LAW -- IS VERY STRICT ON
WHAT THE FINES AND PENALTIES
HAVE TO BE AND SO THEY HAVE NO
DISCRETION RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST
GIVING THEM THAT DISCRETION WITH
A. B..
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE SO WITHOUT BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE.
ARE THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEN UNDER THERE WEREN'T ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS -- WE ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION AND
I I THINK WE JUST HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT
THIS SORT OF UNDERLYING TENSION
THIS CREATES WHERE YOU HAVE
STATE REGULATORS WHO WERE.
TRYING TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND
MAYBE -- SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE ARE TRYING TO COMPLY BUT WE
DON'T KIND IT WANT TO CREATE A A
A WAY OUT FOR THEM -- YOU KNOW
IF IF THEY'RE JUST BEING
NEGLIGENT THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS MIKE WE OWE THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION --
WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION APOLOGIZED WERE GETTING
EARLIER IN THE COMMITTEE LATE --
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE.
A WAY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
EVADE.
PENALTIES -- FOR WORKER HEALTH
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS I'M AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS OVERLY
BROAD ARRAY IS SMALL BUSINESSES
COMPRISE OF 90% OF ALL BUSINESS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
MAKE UP -- THE EMPLOYEE ABOUT
HALF OUR PRIVATE SECTOR WORK
FORCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A BILL
THAT WOULD LIMIT LIABILITY ON
THOSE EMPLOYERS THAT WILL HAVE A
MASSIVE IMPACT ON THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES IN NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES AND THE STATE.
AND IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS MADE UP
OF SMALL BUSINESSES RIGHT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INDUSTRIES LIKE
CONSTRUCTION JANITORIAL.
AGRICULTURAL -- MOST OF THESE
ARE COMPRISED OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT THEY ALSO HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL VIOLATIONS --
ENDED ANOTHER THING WORTH NOTING
IS THAT OUR STATE AGENCIES ARE
STRETCHED THIN -- THAT LABOR
AGENCY DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TODAY ENOUGH STAFF TO
DO THE TO TO COVER ALL THESE
BUSINESSES ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENCIES ARE ALSO STRETCHED TO
THE LIMIT -- EIGHT CAL CAL OSHA
IN -- TWENTY FIFTEEN HAD IT WITH
CITED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR NOT HAVING ENOUGH STAFF TO
DEAL WITH WORKER TO WORKER
COMPLAINTS UNTIMELY WAY.
SO -- IT HAVING CLEAR VIOLATIONS
HAVING CLEAR PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THESE LAWS IS A
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT --
WORKERS IN OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR
PUBLIC ARE SAFE AND IT CREATING
THE SORT OF LOOPHOLE OR A WAY
FOR STATE AGENCIES TO GET OUT OF
COMPLYING WITH THE FLU --
VIOLATIONS THEY'VE SUFFERED IS A
BAD THING -- AND IT'S ALSO WORTH
NOTING AGAIN THAT IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO THAT WE HAD A A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR WHO I WAS
STATEMENT MAYBE DIDN'T
NECESSARILY CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT
WORKER SAFETY ARE UNDERFUNDED
UNDERSTAFFED -- ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENCIES AND LABOR AGENCIES SO
THE BROAD IMPACT THIS BILL COULD
POTENTIALLY ALLOW THESE AGENCIES
TO REDUCE WHO KNOWS HOW MUCH
PENALTIES FOR WORKER SAFETY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IS MADE
EVEN DOWN TO ZERO HE KNOWS.
BUT WE CAN'T JUST LOOK UNDER THE
LANDS OF THE IMPACT OF IT RIGHT
NOW WITH THE SORT OF PROGRESSIVE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CURRENT
GOVERNOR WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THE FUTURE AND SEE HOW CAN THIS
BILL BE USED AND WE'VE WE'VE.
WE FEEL THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS FOR
WORKERS IN OUR COMMUNITY SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
WAIT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
RESPOND.
TO THE GENTLEMAN'S -- ARGUMENT
THERE AS I UNDERSTOOD IT HE'S SO
MAKING. TWO MAIN POINTS ONE IS
THAT -- SOMEHOW YOUR BILL WILL
ALLOW SMALL BUSINESSES AS THE
FINE -- TO ESCAPE LIABILITY AS
OPPOSED TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH LAW AND REGULATION -- AND
HIS AND OTHER POINT IS THAT.
IN SO DOING I THINK THAT WILL
UNDERMINE WORKER PROTECTIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS AND
SUCH OVER THE LONG RUN I WAS
JUST WONDERING IF YOU COULD --
RESPOND TO THOSE TWO POINTS SURE
WELL OUR I AM CERTAINLY VERY
COGNIZANT THAT. ONE OF THE
REASONS STATE REGULATION EXIST
IS TO ENSURE WORKER SAFETY AND
CONSUMER SAFETY SO WE WERE NOT
TRYING TO JEOPARDIZE THOSE.
AT ALL AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE SO
NARROWLY CRAFTED THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH A
BUSINESS COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
RELIEF UNDER THIS IT HAS TO BE.
A A FIRST TIME OFFENSE.
IT HAS TO BE A MINOR VIOLATION
WHICH MEANS THAT SOMETHING THAT
MAJOR WITH THAT AFFECTED WORKER
SAFETY I DON'T DO NOT THINK
WOULD BE COVERED UNDER THIS.
THE BUSINESS HAS TO COOPERATE
WITH THE INVESTIGATION WHICH
MEANS IF THEY'RE TRYING -- TO TO
OBSCURE THE FACT THAT THE
VIOLATION EXISTED THEY DON'T
QUALIFY AND THE VIOLATION MUST
HAVE BEEN CORRECTED WHICH MEANS
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE SO I THINK UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S REALLY
HARD TO ARGUE.
THAT A SMALL BUSINESS SHOULD BE
FINED.
POTENTIALLY A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND AND AND TO BE CLEAR
THIS THIS.
BILL WOULD NOT.
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO
ELIMINATE THE FINE IF THE
BUSINESS COULD PAY THE FINE THEN%
THE FULL AMOUNT OF FINE COULD
STILL BE ASSESSED IF -- THE
STATE AGENCY DETERMINES THAT
PERHAPS A 50% REDUCTION IN THE
FINE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THEY WOULD
BARELY BE EMPOWERED TO DO THAT.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS.
THE ASSERTION THAT THIS WOULD
ALLOW THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TO
THRIVE MORE BECAUSE I THINK THE
OPPOSITE IS VERY WE CLEARLY TRUE.
THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY -- I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN LABOR FEDERATION
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT
OF WORKER SAFETY VIOLATIONS BUT
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNDERGROUND THAT THOSE
VIOLATIONS ARE NOT CAUGHT THERE
NOT BEING FIND RIGHT NOW SO.
I DON'T SEE HOW THIS BILL COULD
POSSIBLY BE CONSTRUED -- TO
EXPAND THEIR RANKS IN FACT I
THINK IT WOULD REDUCE THEIR
RANKS BY HOPEFULLY BRING SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE OUT OF THE SHADOWS
AND AND INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REGULATIONS.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I JUST
HAD MORE GENERAL COMMENT IT --
IT OCCURS TO ME SOME OF THESE.
RUN A SMALL BUSINESS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND AND PROBABLY
MORE PERMANENTLY REPRESENTED
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE IN THE
LEGAL SYSTEM -- I THINK YOU'RE
GETTING A REALLY.
VIABLE ISSUE I MEAN THE READ THE
REALITY IS IF IF YOU'RE.
IF YOU'RE WALMART ARE YOUR
STARBUCKS OR YOU'RE A MAJOR
CORPORATION YOU HAVE THE MONEY.
TO HIRE LAND USE LAWYERS YOU
HAVE THE MONEY TO HIRE OTHER
LAWYERS YOU HAVE THE MONEY TO
PAY FINES IF YOU GET FIND YOU
HAVE THE MONEY.
TO HIRE CONSULTANTS TO TELL YOU
HOW TO NOT GET FINE YOU HAVE
RESOURCES THAT CAN ALLOW YOU --
THE THE ABILITY TO MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW ABOUT ALL THE REGULATIONS
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE UNDER
POTENTIALLY UNDER AND TO TAKE
REMEDIAL ACTION -- STE A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESS OR JUST SIMPLY
NOT IN THAT -- CIRCUMSTANCE AND
I CAN TELL YOU IF YOU'VE NEVER
HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
REPRESENTING SOMEBODY WHO'S HIT
WITH THE CIVIL PENALTY OR A
LAWSUIT.
AND THEY'RE GOING.
EITHER I PAY THAT OR A P. THAT
SETTLEMENT RIGHT PAY THAT FINE
OR A WAY OFF.
MARY AND JOHN AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND YOU'VE EVER TRIED
TO WALK SOMEBODY THROUGH THAT --
EXPERIENCE A CAN BE CRUSHING IT
CAN BE CRUSHING TO SMALL
BUSINESS AND I DON'T THINK LOOK.
I'M A 100% ON BOARD WITH WORKER
SAFETY CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION BUT
THERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
REGULATIONS.
ON SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE THAT I THINK
THAT IS ON ALMOST UNDENIABLE.
BOB SO THIS BUILDS ON AN EFFORT
I'VE BEEN MAKING SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH MY SMALL BUSINESS
WAYS ON BILL THE GOVERNOR SIGNED.
I THINK IT'S A POSITIVE STEP --
I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE TRYING TO NARROWLY TAILOR
SOMETHING THAT GETS A REAL ISSUE
AND THAT'S LIKE GIVE PEOPLE A
CHANCE BEFORE YOU BRING THE
HOUSE DOWN ON A MOM AND POP.
GIVE PEOPLE THE CHANCE TO BRING.
THEIR MINOR VIOLATIONS IN THE
COMPLIANCE -- AND AND I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD STEP UNHAPPY
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH -- I ECHO THE THE
SENTIMENT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHEN I SPEAK
WITH SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS IN MY
COMMUNITY RESOUNDINGLY.
THEY WANT TO BE COMPLIANT THEY
SIMPLY ARE OVERWHELMED OFTEN BY
THE TASK AT HAND AND SO I THINK
ON THE WAY THIS HAS BEEN CRAFTED
IN A VERY TARGETED WAY SPEAKS TO
THAT.
SPEAKS TO THE IDEA OF GETTING TO
YES FOR BOTH PARTIES CONCERNED
AND FIND COMPLIANCE WITH STILL
KEEPING OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES THRIVING SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU.
WELL I WILL CLOSE BY THINKING IN
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORD AND BUT ALSO LISTENING
TO THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION AFTER READING THE
BILL -- AND JACK THEN READING
WHAT QUALIFIES FOR PENALTY
REDUCTION IN ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS -- THAT WERE POSED
EARLIER I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK IF WE HAVE A
MOTION.
SO IT WAS WITH MOTIONED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AND
SECONDED BY OUR VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
NUMBER NINE A. B. FIFTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
CHAIR CERVANTES AYE.
CHAU CERVANTES ON FOSTER
CUNNINGHAM.
OYSTER CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
CHANNEL I CHEN.
CHEN I BROMUS REAVIS.
BE THIS ICE SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH HI. SEVEN SIX ZERO ABOUT
BILL REMAIN ON CALL OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TAKE YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE CERVANTES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION ITEM SEVEN
AB THREE SEVENTY ONE FRAZIER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION.
ITEM EIGHT AB SIX THIRTY NINE
CERVANTES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES.
CHAIR CERVANTES HI.
CERVANTES ANA PLACER ALAN --
SKEWS ME BUSTER CUNNINGHAM.
BUT YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM -- IT CHAU.
CHAO A IT CHEN.
CHEN FIVE RAMOS.
RUBUS.
RUBLES A DAY SMITH.
SMITH [inaudible] ONE NOW WILL
BE PLACED ON CALL.
I WILL BE LIFTING THAT ALL CALLS.
IF I CAN HAVE THE SECRETARY.
JUST LIST THE CAN BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE I REMEMBER THREE AS HE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWO FORTY FIVE
ITEM THREE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE ITEM FOR AB.
TWO THIRTY ITEM FIVE AB EIGHTEEN
AWAIT ITEM SIX AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE NINE NINE AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE SO -- ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB.
TWO FORTY FIVE BUT
SECRETARY CAN
YOU CALL THE NAMES OF THE ABSENT
MEMBERS
.
WE WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWO FOUR FIVE SECRETARY
PLEASE UP IN THE ROLE.
ITEM ONE A. B..
TWO FORTY FIVE THE MOTIONS DO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FASTER CUNNINGHAM.
BUT YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM ONLINE
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CHEN HI [inaudible]
SKIP [inaudible]
CHEN NUMBERING [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
CHAU.
WE CAN MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TO AB.
SEVEN FOUR TWO I DO NUMBER TO AB
SEVEN FORTY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION [inaudible]
RAMOS.
WELL WE'VE GOT ITEM ON CALL ITEM
THREE A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE ITEM THREE
A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
WHO?
MRS DEPENDS WITH THE MINISTER
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION
[inaudible]
CONTENT
.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB.
TWO THIRTY SECRETARY OF PLEASE
OF THE CALL.
ITEM FOR AB TWO THIRTY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
BY SIR CUNNINGHAM.
FACED HER CUNNINGHAM HI CHANNEL.
CHANNEL.
FIVE RAMOS.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT PLEASE OF THE
CALL.
BOB THE MEMBERS.
ITEM FIVE AB EIGHTEEN AWAY TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
RUMORED TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
EIGHTEEN OH NINE WE DO WE JUST
DO THAT ONE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B..
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE AT THE
COFFEE.
SO WE ARE WAITING FOR ONE MEMBER
.
GO THROUGH.
THE ITEMS.
OKAY. TWENTY TWO THE CENTER.
WE WILL LET THE CON ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB.
TWO FORTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWO FORTY FIVE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
YES.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWO THIRTY
PLEASE OF THE CALL.
I DO NUMBER FOUR AB TWO THIRTY
THE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
[inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS I SEVEN ZERO ABOUT BILL IS
OUT.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE A.
B..
EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE A. B. EIGHTEEN AWAIT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO SOME THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS HI.
THAT'S SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SIX A. B. EIGHTEEN OH NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
RAMOS.
FROM WAS I SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THAT THOSE OUT.
AND LAST ITEMS A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NINE A. B. FIFTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
RAMOS. SIX ZERO ABOUT BILL IS
OUT
.
SO WE WILL GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M CONSENT ITEM THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE CERVANTES
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION ITEM SEVEN
A. B.. THREE SEVENTY ONE FRAZIER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ITEM EIGHT AB SIX
THIRTY NINE CERVANTES THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES.
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS HI [inaudible] SEVEN ZERO
I SEVEN ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TO AB.
SEVEN FOUR TWO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION.
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS HI.
THAT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO IN THE
BILL IS OUT.
WITHOUT I WILL JUST TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU